this is gonna be a total disaster
it's gonna be a really long day i hope
this works since
it's not the prettiest sauce
looks great you guys this is like the
coolest thing i've ever done
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of chef
out of water i'm alexis a chef who's
always up for a challenge we've taken to
the internet to ask you what appliance i
should use to make a three-course meal
got something very large next to me
which makes me a little nervous shall we
see what's in there
what is it
mini dishwasher
are these my tools i know you can make a
salmon in the dishwasher so i know
something is possible
i have absolutely no idea what i'm gonna
do but i do have heat and i feel like
with so many episodes i just ask for
heat so i have something i need to do a
lot of research okay let's see what's
possible in a dishwasher someone's tried
to cook chicken breast in a dishwasher
which sounds truly offensive lasagna
feels hard okay it seems like there's a
lot of seafood that gets poached in
dishwashers with relative success really
good to know meat feels a little iffy
obviously the skin won't brown so you
get like weird floppy skin i think i'm
gonna stay away from meat today it gets
up to like 150 degrees to see weed it
needs to be between like 131 and 140
degrees so i think i need to look at
this like a giant sous vide the shortest
cycle is about 40 minutes and i need to
be really smart about time here i'm
gonna try to do everything at once gotta
list ryan he's gonna go shopping while i
get my head around this thing we'll see
what happens ryan
for my first course today i'm gonna do a
spring vegetable
salad with a sauce grabish gribish is a
traditional french sauce i think it'll
add some brightness and i'm going to put
it over asparagus green beans and
english peas i think it could work my
controversy i feel like my emotions are
so erratic right now i just like
like a five i'm gonna get some jars this
really feels like a craft project okay
so some beans i'm not totally sure how
much water i'm gonna add a bay leaf some
peppercorns i mean if this works it's
gonna be really cool some salt and a
lemon peel
[Music]
well one thing done
i've got some english peas i'm gonna do
exactly the same thing
bay leaf some peppercorns salt a lemon
peel
look at that this is like my little
laboratory
okay i've got some beautiful asparagus
here so i'm just gonna have them
on the bias let's do the same thing
some salt bay leaf some peppercorns
a lemon peel
[Music]
looks great
i'm worried about the eggs like knocking
into each other so i got you know i only
need one for the dressing
but one more egg
oh no
okay
yeah maybe making it a little more
secure a little more snug it's a little
egg mist
of course one
for my second course i'm going to make
butter poached lobster tails and then
make lobster rolls from the tails i mean
this seems so weird but i'm gonna put
the tails in the jar
and then put the butter and some
water adding some garlic cloves might
add some flavor more lemon peel
and salt
oh this is so weird moving on to dessert
for my
third and final course i'm going to make
poached strawberries and make kind of a
parfait first i've got to start with my
strawberries i could haul these which
just means like using the tip to go all
the way around the stem and then you
just pop it out like that quarter feels
nice this feels good on the strawberry
front i can add some water and some
sugar
[Music]
sugar oh my god i've done that so many
times
oh no oh no
did i seriously just play salt
i cannot be trusted
some lemon
i also have a vanilla bean
which i thought would really like infuse
it with that amazing
flavor want to split it down the middle
open it up and then use a paring knife
to press down and scrape the seeds
oh my god it's like gold and i'm
actually going to add the
pods in too because it's just more
flavor
this is my meal my entire meal is right
here it's dishwasher time
great
off to a great start fill it with water
god this is small
first i'm going to put my
lobster in
and my eggs
just nestled
nice together and then i've got my peas
my green beans
and asparagus
and then my strawberries easy
this is crazy here goes nothing
okay i'm gonna put it on baby care which
is gonna be like the steamiest
it's also two hours oh my god
this stuff is gonna cook way sooner than
two hours
[Music]
okay well this gets going i'm going to
whip some cream and smash some cookies
for my little parfait i've been here so
many times before
i can't believe i keep choosing to do it
again
okay
whipped cream is
looking swoopy
okay
wow
back to the cream just a little bit of
sugar
whipped cream
i'm gonna have ryan put this in the
fridge and then i'm gonna smash
some of my cookies some people might say
that this is cheating a little bit
because i'm using store-bought cookies
but
you're not making the meal with the
dishwasher so
my journey
that's it we just gotta wait for uh this
food to cook i thought two hours was
gonna be way too much time but i just
did a little more research and it turns
out for both eggs and lobster
they sous-vide for about an hour at 1 35
and it's been 30 minutes and it's only
at 109 so i actually think the two hours
is going to be perfect i feel very
relaxed right now my emotional
level is like a 10
my confidence level for
food is like a six
so my little dishwasher's been going for
about an hour and i just want to do a
little quick check to make sure
it's cooking or something's happening
oh wow she's stainy
i guess we'll start by seeing how the
asparagus tastes
a lot of crunch
not
bad but definitely needs more time it's
actually not that hot either
the beans have not cooked at all
since
oh god
that looks um really disgusting
pungent
the lobster meat is definitely cooking
but it's still
not fully opaque
so
it needs more time the eggs honestly i'm
not even gonna check they need more time
if the bean isn't cooked the egg is
certainly not cooked
i think i'm gonna let it go for another
like 45 minutes
she's hot 154
i let it go for another hour rather than
45 minutes but i think it's ready
the lobster looks insane
it smells good
well the tails have turned red which is
usually the sign that they're cut to
open a lobster tail pretty easy use some
handy dandy kitchen scissors and you
just want to cut the
underside of the lobster and then you
can just peel the shell back
crack it open it's actually like pretty
beautiful
it's like really beautiful
maybe we're all gonna be cooking lobster
in uh dishwashers i'm just gonna cut off
a tiny bit to see
it's delicious
it's like
delicious it's so
buttery
this is amazing
you know even if everything else fails
this is incredible
my lobster is going in a little bowl and
i'm gonna dress it up with some mayo
some lemon before adding it to my bun
moment of truth on the eggs ooh one
cracked
oh one opened oh god oh god some of the
yolk got out it's pretty gross
okay this one is still fully
raw
and like snotty oh my god gross the egg
did not work
the egg was not great i have one egg
left in here
and i'm gonna put it back for like 30
more minutes
to hopefully get it because it's like
it's cook it's cooking it's just not
she's not cooked
oh jiggles too
let's see about the vegetables
the peas ooh are leaky the peas look a
little overcooked a little gray
the color is like really not great
[Music]
but the flavor is
fine they're a little cooked they've got
quite a bit of crunch
moment of truth on the strawberries
which should look like a lot of their
color has been removed
smells incredible that's so good it's
sweet it's not too sweet
strawberries are cooked perfectly they
have a little bit of bite they're not
mushy eggs are going back in
[Music]
i'm gonna start dressing my lobster roll
i've got my beautifully cooked lobster
meat just gonna add some mayo
some lemon juice
a little bit of salt
that's it
just lay it in there i like seeing a
little bit of red the meat in my lobster
buns it looks amazing
i think this is my treat
[Music]
it's so good and to add some chives on
top my entree is done i'm so excited
about this lobster roll i'm gonna move
on to dessert while my egg finishes
cooking
onto dessert i am gonna do like a
parfait
this is
really exciting okay i'm gonna do a
layer of my crushed cookies a layer of
whipped cream
layer of strawberries
another layer of crumbs
oh wow
poached strawberry parfait maiden
dishwasher
complete
my machine has stopped so
egg time let's try this again
egg is cooked now
that is a beautiful egg for a gribish
i'd really like it to be harder but
honestly if the dishwasher did this like
no complaints this is so cool
got the chopped up egg i'm gonna add
some capers and some cornish little
french pickles
i'm gonna add some dijon mustard
some champagne vinegar gonna give it all
stir it's not the prettiest sauce and
then i'm gonna just drizzle in some
olive oil some salt pepper i feel like
the vegetables look kind of overcooked
and the sauce
does not look that appetizing i kind of
feel like this is as good as it's gonna
get
this is not what i envisioned in any way
oh
i needed to add parsley to it too
sauce gribish everyone there's a reason
you don't see it on menus anymore i'm
gonna add some parsley
some flaky sea salt my confidence level
on this dish it's not great i feel like
10 on the lobster roll anton dessert but
like
this
three
that feels generous
i think this is as good as it's gonna
get the good news is that it gets better
as the meal goes on let's see what our
taste tester has to say
this is my friend joyce hi
joyce i made you a three-course meal
today using this which i will reveal to
you after okay that makes me nervous but
i trust your cooking course one is a
spring vegetable
salad
with gravish which is a type of french
sauce
that looks good
it definitely has the earthy taste to it
i like them you like it health healthy
this is very healthy you know it gets
better from here mm-hmm for your entree
i have a lobster roll for you
[Music]
i love a lobster roll oh pretty
instagram me and bait 20 20.
wow
that's delicious
for the last course i've got a little
poached strawberry parfait for you this
is what i deserve you do i deserve this
every day
i'm going to try it too
it's delicious
oh my god you look really good girl
thank you damn
the big question
what do you think i made this meal with
an air dryer that's not that far off
are you ready to see i'm so scared
ready
it's a dishwasher first of all you get a
portable dishwasher do i need that
period second of all how did you make
this and that
got to watch the episode damn girl you
can really cook
okay girl well thank you
i have hopes to feed i'll see you guys
later
bye
i wasn't sure what to think about the
dishwasher but turns out i love it you
can do so much let me know in the
comments what you thought of the dishes
that i made with a dishwasher today see
you next time on chef out of water
[Music]
you